estamos en la región de vigo va en el
extremo al norte de irak a menos de 15
kilómetros detrás de esas montañas está
turquía pero en todas partes aquí la
presencia de ankara ya se siente hay
muchas bases militares turcas en la
región durante nuestro informe fuimos
testigos de la presencia de drones en el
cielo y de vehículos militares turcos en
las carreteras los lugareños con los que
hablamos se negaron a testificar frente
a nuestra cámara por temor a posibles
represalias
nos dijeron que ahora consideran la zona
como territorio turco este acuerdo es el
único que aceptó hablar con nosotros por
razones de seguridad
decidimos no revelar su identidad es
oriundo de la región pero la dejó hace
años para huir del peligro la situación
en esta zona no es nada agradable porque
porque turquía nos quitó cualquier razón
válida para quedarnos
turquía podía golpear a cualquiera sin
preguntarse quién era el civil u otra
persona esta casa está abandonada por
esa razón
podría ser bombardeado de nuevo y la
gente perdería la vida
según una reciente comisión de
investigación del parlamento kurdo más
de 500 aldeas han sido abandonadas en el
norte de irak debido al conflicto entre
turquía y el pkk nuestro interlocutor
solo ingresa a su región natal para
trabajar hoy en día vivimos en las
ciudades y ganarse la vida en la ciudad
es muy difícil pero debido a turquía
nadie puede volver a vivir en estos
pueblos bombardean a diario
estos vídeos de los bombardeos fueron
tomados el día antes de que llegáramos a
la escena apuntan a los rebeldes kurdos
del pkk en guerra con turquía desde 1984
el ejército turco está llevando a cabo
operaciones regulares en el norte de
irak desde hace tres décadas pero rara
vez combinan operaciones aéreas y
terrestres como fue el caso durante tres
meses este año más de una docena de
civiles murieron en estos ataques el 11
de agosto los altos oficiales iraquíes
ajenos al conflicto murieron en uno de
esos ataques cuando se reunieron con
miembros del pkk para pedirles que
abandonaran su zona de control
mohamed rachid el corán a la izquierda y
su vera librados está a su lado marta
one es el hijo de este último
el mártir su vera librados ti fue
asesinado de manera perdida los dos
generales viajaron a la zona en uniforme
y vehículo militar iraquí estos
oficiales vinieron por orden de bagdad
si turquía tiene un problema con eso que
hablé con el gobierno de bagdad y que no
cruce la frontera para matar a dos
generales después del ataque
bagdad de reaccionó cancelando la visita
del ministro de defensa turco por su
lado el pdk el partido democrático kurdo
a la cabeza del gobierno autónomo del
kurdistán iraquí se abstiene de todo
comentario
el mártir psuv era librados y era
miembro del pdk y trabajaba para la
patrulla fronteriza de las fuerzas
iraquíes por recomendación del pdk así
que el pdk debería intervenir y trabajar
con el gobierno kurdo y el gobierno
iraquí para encontrar una resolución y
darle una respuesta al caso ante el
conflicto actual los kurdos están
divididos el pdk que está
particularmente bien establecido en
erbil tiene muy buenas relaciones
comerciales con ankara el 80 por ciento
de los productos importados al kurdistán
iraquí proviene de turquía
para brindarse bar y funcionario de
promoción internacional del gobierno
regional del kurdistán también conocido
como gsk mantener buenas relaciones con
ankara es una garantía de estabilidad
y nuestro pueblo en el kurdistán iraquí
sufre este conflicto hay personas
desplazadas y problemas de seguridad
pero al mismo tiempo el xerez ya está
decidido en mantener una muy buena
relación con turquía como actor clave y
como socio comercial el pdk condena los
bombardeos turcos en el norte de irak
pero considera al pkk como el principal
responsable el pkk debe respetar la
integridad territorial del kurdistán
iraquí para no causar más daño y más
caos en las zonas fronterizas y para no
dar a turquía una buena excusa para
intervenir vamos al noreste de la región
a una hora del monte candil donde uno de
los portavoces del pkk accedió a
reunirse con nosotros incluso aquí cerca
de las ciudades sus miembros temen los
bombardeos nuestros contactos nos piden
que apaguemos nuestros teléfonos de
celulares y cambiamos el lugar de
encuentro varias veces
los drones están sobre el área 724 ahora
mismo en este momento no puedo decir que
su actividad esté totalmente concentrada
aquí así que creo que es relativamente
seguro si hacemos la entrevista ahora lo
más rápido posible
ninguno de estos miembros es oriundo del
kurdistán iraquí pero su presencia es
legítima en la zona dicen en nombre de
la causa kurda que no tiene fronteras
según ellos
la causa kurda es un todo y todo partido
kurdo o mejor dicho todo kurdo sabe que
erdogán es el principal enemigo de los
kurdos de menem y le pedimos que
comenten los vínculos entre el pdk
dirigido por la familia barzani y
turquía en un momento en el que se
intensifican las operaciones militares
contra miembros del pkk y el pdk los
barça nos colaboran con turquía para
frenar un movimiento kurdo en turquía
sería mejor que los barça nos pidieran a
turquía que resolviera la cuestión kurda
de forma pacífica y democrática en lugar
de trabajar con turquía contra los
kurdos
las negociaciones entre turquía y el pkk
iniciaron a finales de 2012 y condujeron
a un alto al fuego que finalmente se
rompió en 2015
desde entonces la ong internacional
crisis el grupo estima que más de 5000
personas han muerto en los combates de
las cuales casi 600 han sido en irak